es habitual que la asamblea nacional
popular apruebe todas las propuestas que
le envía el partido por mayoría absoluta
y un puñado apenas simbólico de votos
negativos y abstenciones pero esta
mañana se votaba el tercer mandato
presidencial de y no ha habido mayoría
absoluta sino unanimidad 2952 si es
entre 2952 delegados tras la votación ha
habido un minuto de ovación cerrada en
el gran palacio del pueblo y si ha
Jurado sobre una copia Roja de la
Constitución china su tercer mandato
llega después de una reforma
constitucional de 2018 que acabó con los
límites que había establecido
denshopping el arquitecto de las
reformas que quiso evitar que se
repitieran concentraciones de poder como
la que durante el maoísmo provocó
desastres como la revolución cultural o
el gran salto adelante el cargo es de
todas formas mucho menos relevante que
el de secretario general del partido
wellde jefe de la comisión Central
Militar
es un cargo puramente simbólico que
durante muchos años sirvió para premiar
a políticos veteranos y que en la
actualidad se utiliza en reuniones con
dirigentes extranjeros en esta asamblea
también se está menguando otra de las
precauciones que había establecido
denshopping es el equilibrio entre
partido y gobierno cada vez más
decantado al primero que está tomando el
poder en áreas que antes correspondían
al segundo hablamos por ejemplo de los
sectores de la seguridad o la tecnología